public conference is the key challenge
with them and it hasn't necessarily
emanated just from low-level crimes
there have been a series of high profile
incidents and instance of mismanagement
but it's going to have to be
neighborhood policing investigating
level crimes part of the Mets route back
to being a trusted performance because
as Katie says one of the challenges is
that polling recently said about 40 of
people wouldn't bother reporting a crime
if it happened to them because they
don't think it would be investigated now
that's a nightmare for the future
because you can't spot patterns you
can't spot Trends and you can't solve
crime